while these I do not like Oh which one
it is it really doesn't help the way
them all at the same time
[Music]
so we're at Rocket Park in Houston Texas
and we're in spacesuits so I thought
it'd be cool if we tried astronaut ice
cream all right yeah let's do this do
the first one we're trying is chocolate
ice cream with chocolate chips the
presentation is not the best on the
inside they were kind of just like here
it is Cheers
oh wow you know the texture is exactly
like Lucky Charms
marshmallows you want one more on a
scale of one rocket to 10 rocket how
good was this one I'd say at least seven
I'm a chocolate lover I'm gonna give
this an eight I'm gonna take another
bite nurse when we're trying is Ice
Cream Sandwich oh they're really got the
look of the Ice Cream Sandwich down kind
of has more of like a toast texture I
think I like how cool and refreshing ice
cream is so it's just really weird
don't put that six rockets I'm gonna
give that one a 5/5 rockets we got some
freeze-dried mint chocolate chip ice
cream
cool alive
[Music]
it's like taking a bite of error mint is
supposed to hit you in like a cool old
way I'll taste like mink gum was hanging
in my mouth for way too long
I give this a - I was gonna say one but
I am still eating it so I'm gonna go
with two kind of a Neapolitan style ice
cream
Neapolitan all right pretty excited
about this one I used to only eat the
chocolate part because I didn't like
anything else how did everyone else in
the family feel about that I was the
unloved child probably first all right
hey you should really put one of each in
your mouth at the same time that's how
people eat apologize okay thanks random
strangers sure I like it you know this
was like that nice kind of flavor of all
the ice creams just kind of working as
one in perfect harmony
I think the strawberry is the one I
don't like there's just like not enough
strawberry flavor and it's more just
like hard marshmallow flavor I'm gonna
give this a seven like combine a 1/4 the
strawberry like negative 8 to bring it
down to 1 out of 10 where's that equal 1
I need this any time yeah you know you
don't even have to be in space you can
enjoy this anywhere you know what if we
were in space we wouldn't have options
we've learned something today being an
astronaut is very hard but ice-cream can
make it better
unless it's men and wasn't it more
strawberry
[Music]